how's Gummer my name is Pierre back
welcome to Colleen your Silencio [ __ ]
love this game sis a nice game
you know there's dragons hey dragons see
they're really chill and there's trees
what more can you want
seriously like there's more than one
tree
I think I was supposed to empty
mariota's to decide a gun hey Drago
stop being an attention hood Chase is
tight
yeah I think it's summer here it could
be over yeah that's it I need a lot
though [ __ ] we don't have a key
or do we maybe I wasn't break it if I
hit it hard all right that's what I was
trying and during the boss fight but I
didn't [ __ ] right b'fer
your time to shine has arrived please do
it before the diner comes that [ __ ]
right what no I just [ __ ] hit it hard
what's the problem I know it's [ __ ]
line
don't make me click I click stupid this
thing oh come come oh [ __ ] me we're
going down there aren't we oh that does
not sound well
oh alright I just want to look for ammo
or some [ __ ] because that we're really
lacking it right now this place is not
seem friendly and weird [ __ ] going
down there alright
pray for me Bruce oh [ __ ] I got goose
bumps just now you can't see it oh [ __ ]
this is not good hello friendly
creatures of the sewers please approach
me oh hello oh this is not good I'm
turning off my light stealth mode
activate don't kill me just a man oh
[ __ ]
hello what is that
it's that frog frog this frogs live in
the sewers Helen
oh okay okay that's normal
my mama told me about your sewer frogs
the thing is I don't even think frogs
sound like that set bad frogs okay okay
okay okay
don't even worry about it don't even
worry about it okay I know what I'm
doing I don't have a sewer
Hey Oh skip skip cool that's just a
[ __ ] night oh oh hello Jess why have
you been all my life I need you so much
what is this shotgun shells shotgun
shells oh man I love this shocking so
much thank God I ran in here that's what
you get for being lost I guess nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein victor
victor
shun you forged fracker bad frog bad
frog you're not supposed to mutate all
your friend came don't give a [ __ ] come
here bad frog
gotta make sure they're [ __ ] dead too
they're dead bad frogs bad frogs what
you gotta do what you're gonna do when
the frog at you bad frogs bad well I
wasn't so bad was it can I go here not
sure if I want to go there what I don't
think we can go there can go here though
see - is that supposed to be a clue
keep out let's [ __ ] go that's how
horror games work all right come on oh
[ __ ]
I'll shed
I got so much I'm shivering like a
[ __ ] don't even worry about it
brothers I totally know what I'm doing
I'm an expert at running around like an
idiot oh thank god
thank you so is it more safe is now than
before or I'm again actually getting
better at this game what is this thing
I'm gonna pick it up [ __ ] all right
ride on well at least we got some rifle
shells what I'm back where I started
son of a [ __ ] I thought I actually saw
this
- this
[ __ ] me I found a key now alright at
least I have the key now so the question
is where the [ __ ] did we put it I know
there was a boy I was lying which one
worked where was the door lock yeah it's
down there alright oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
was that
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
this is not good this is not good this
is [ __ ] run that's this [ __ ] run
that's just [ __ ] run let's [ __ ]
run let's just [ __ ] run let's just
[ __ ] run let's just [ __ ] run
lights just talking wrong no [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I went the wrong direction I'm a
[ __ ] idiot I'm sweating a lot because
I'm not scared or anything hello Braga
crew can I marry you go straight go
straight go [ __ ] straight kids you
can go straight fake way is the best way
even if you're not gay you can go my way
through the pie or the halfway up frog
how you doing I just want to know
because I don't [ __ ] know alright
let's go hey frog smell - that's why
don't
all right have a good rest don't even
worry about Lily don't even worry about
it
are you worried ha ha ha ha ha
that's silly you're silly I was talking
a little silly all righty then
all right oh [ __ ] cockroaches don't even
worry about it they can harm me nothing
to touch me
okay so the ladder is on the right side
and that's how we probably imputed to a
town [ __ ] we can stare at Harry's ass
for a couple second I liked it I liked
it I liked it a lot I liked it I liked
it up [ __ ] more sewer huh all right this
is just fantastic
ah more fries shaba daba daba la dama
you frogs damn you damn you damn I curse
you to hell
look at my health I don't know [ __ ] you
frog dot I told you not to I said look
at my health not kill me it's a big
difference huge different alright that
road is blocked I check all the hair
just for funsies
I don't think I'll get any fun sees I
think I'll get [ __ ] sees alrighty then
it's up with this it's better cake it's
no
goddamnit well frog is then I probably
how your day
alright that means we got to go over hey
I think nope [ __ ]
ceiling frog is you don't [ __ ] with them
oh [ __ ]
I may even walk in the right that yes I
am all right this is day let's go let's
just go let's just go let's just get the
[ __ ] out of here
say bye to froggy cockroaches hi hi hi
hi nice meeting it I was like yeah it's
getting you got a flag with them
otherwise they'd kill you
thank God like literally I really needed
you alright
should I drink it that's the question
yes I [ __ ] [ __ ] that you are a my
lovely there you are cockroaches let me
grab this ammo for [ __ ] sake I need a
not not funny cockroaches ah [ __ ] three
hits that's three more than I should
have taken let's go in here totally
worth it totally why you don't even
worry about it
totally know what I'm doing an FBI Oh
frog it for how you doing alright cool
alright so now we just go to the left
and I'm sure everything will go really
well and this door [ __ ] locked
froggy thrown up [ __ ] when they're right
now
god dammit this is Todd I don't have
time for this
it's bad enough a frog get frozen here
or Pittacus it's gonna be angry really
angry really really alright alright
alright alright alright alright alright
alright alright alright alright
all [ __ ] right
all right keep out you can't tell me
what to do door doors don't tell me [ __ ]
okay now what Plan C pits I don't have a
plan C only a plan owner and that is to
run and [ __ ] everything in run
I meant literally [ __ ] penetrated all
right oh this is nice
AB this nice I'm John whoa look at that
Oh blood cool I love blood have I ever
said that period everywhere the server's
exit key don't kill me
no no I'm sorry pictures up okay okay
I'm sorry I didn't know it was your
period all right you gonna target for it
all right I kill you I kill all of you
don't [ __ ] it out there while I'm
killing stop [ __ ] each other all
right all right frogs I get it I get it
now you all want to [ __ ] today but you
can't I know it's horrible
take it then I have it did I take it I
took it
what is my health doing don't even worry
about it breath oh I am so much house
all right don't even worry about it i
don't know one day I have no idea what
I'm going I'm glad I went back to kill
the Fugees please dr. cockroach's I'm
not gonna die from [ __ ] cockroach
all right it's a little shaky all the
Hey
I know I told I thought I'd write we
can't do this we can do this
hello [ __ ] rookie [ __ ] you very much
control oh [ __ ] what the hell was that
not today cockroach eek yes baby just
baby success [ __ ] drop me and you
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
then I'd hey although it's guarded by
fruit cares oh so close
ah no alright looks like I'll have fun
replaying next episode anyway like a
brave the few died
you don't have to but you know it helps
anyway thank you breath
[Music]
you